Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire with you
once again to help close out what has been quite
a crazy week, to put it mildly. So without further
ado. Right. Let's just jump right in to today's
story. No need to waste time. Let's get to it.
Big story happened this week. The FBI raided
the homes of two individuals involved in
Donald Trump's fake elector scheme. Those two
individuals are Brad Carver, who allegedly
signed a document to be a Trump elector, as well
as Thomas Lane, who worked on Trump's effort to
overturn the election in Arizona and New Mexico.
Now, as everybody I'm sure is aware, the DOJ
is, in fact investigating the fake elector
scheme. It's one of the few things from the
former Trump administration that is actually
being investigated, along with, of course,
the 15 boxes of documents that were found down
at Mar a Lago. The DOJ is also investigating that
with regard to January six, though, not so much.
We get more to that in just a little bit. But this
is a big one, right? We got a fake elector. We got
a guy running Donald Trump's, you know, day to day
campaign operations. The FBI raided their homes,
has seized some of their electronic devices.
And on top of that, other people also
involved in the scheme have received
subpoenas. So here is what this means so
far for this investigation. It just means
that it's moving forward. I know that's a
little disappointing. I know nobody ever just
wants to hear that the wheels are in motion.
Right. We want action. We want meat. We want
something of substance that we can really sink
our teeth into and feel better about these,
you know, kind of slow rolling investigations,
which let's be clear, that is what this is.
I saw a great analysis from a writer this week
that basically said the DOJ is moving too slowly
on this particular story, considering
the fact that this fake elector scheme
didn't just emerge on Tuesday during those
hearings. We've known about it for over a year.
And we're just now getting to the point where,
okay, well, these are the fake electors. Now
let's go look in their homes, let's get their
electronic devices. Let's really start to
ramp things up a little bit. I guess
whatever it is, it is to slow. But sometimes.
Sometimes it's slow for a reason. Other times it's
slow. Out of abundance of caution. And I'm afraid
that is the situation that we are looking at right
now. The DOJ, led by a course Attorney General
Merrick Garland, doesn't want to give any kind of
appearance that they were being overtly political.
They want to make sure that they have
crossed their T's and dotted their eyes
before they make any moves on anyone. Even some
of these low level individuals. But even still,
sometimes when you have the evidence, you don't
need to sit on it. You don't need the weight.
You don't need to hold off on issuing subpoenas
until the public is squarely in your corner.
Sometimes you have to do something, even if
it's unpopular, if it is the right thing to do.
And I do believe that that, of course, is the
situation that we're looking at right now with
the fake elector scheme. I mean, after
all, that is one of the biggest things.
Obviously, there is so much with January six than
with the January six committee and all of that
that we could probably pop a lot of people for a
lot of different crimes right away. Trump, himself
included. And again, I'm going to get to that in
just a few moments. But. This fake elector scheme.
This was the big gambit, right? They knew
that their court cases were losing. They
knew they didn't have evidence of voter fraud.
But they pushed ahead with all of this anyway.
And in some states, yeah, they had people ready
to go in Michigan. We found out this week that
they're fake elector scheme because the electors
had to be in the state capital to cast their
votes. So what they had planned, which of course,
didn't come to fruition, but they had planned to
somehow sneak into the Michigan state capital
so that they would be present the following day
to be able to cast their fake Electoral College
vote. I mean, that is how deep this scheme went.
I mean, this truly is, you know, cross-country.
You know, north to south, south, east to west,
all over the country. You had these little
fake electors willing to do whatever it took.
To make Donald Trump the winner of the election.
So thank goodness, of course, that we do have the
DOJ investigating this. You know, thank goodness
we're seeing some of these positive step forward.
Individuals do need to be subpoenaed. They do
need to you know, if they're not going to comply,
if we think they might hide or destroy evidence,
they do have to be raided. That's how that works.
That's why, by the way, that typically works
in that manner. If you have an individual
you think could destroy evidence, could be
hiding things, that's when you send the FBI
in to go try to find it. Now, over in Georgia as
well, the fake elector scheme has been gaining
steam and we have seen in recent weeks several of
the people who signed on to be the fake electors,
not, of course, necessarily in a criminal
way. And what I mean by that is you do have
some of the people who were the, quote, fake
electors in Georgia that are fully cooperating
with the investigators because they said, listen,
I was approached with this and they said if these
court cases overturn everything for Donald Trump,
we're going to need our electors. Are you willing
to do that? And so you had plenty of people in the
state of Georgia, these Republicans, who said, oh,
yeah, we'll do it if, if and only if these court
cases overturn the election. I'm here ready to go.
And then once the court case is lost, these
people said, all right, I'm out. I'm not going to
do this. And those people have been working with
these investigators both in Georgia and the feds.
And more importantly, they've
been giving them names.
They said, Listen, I'm more than willing to talk
to you, but I'm probably not the guy you need.
You need, you know, this person, this person in
this person, the names have not been released.
So they are getting better leads. And the more
leads you get, the longer the investigation takes,
the more people you have to question, the more
people you have to subpoena. And of course,
you have to go to the courts to get the subpoenas.
So maybe it's being slow rolled out of that
abundance of caution, which I do believe
is the driving factor. But it also could be
that there's just so many different leads, so
many different states, so many different players
that this investigation kind of has to go
slow. Because you don't want to miss anyone.
And sometimes in our impatience and I'll admit
I'm probably public enemy number one on that.
Sometimes we forget about that. You know, we
all want this kind of instant gratification with
these investigations. And unfortunately, that's
just not the way it works. So we do have to be
patient. We do have to let the process play itself
out because there are far too many players here.
For us to even admit, ignore
or forget a single one of them